right time for today's bar chart how low
could the Euro fall in
2015 now it started the year at
$1 2098 having dropped 12% in 2014 that
was its biggest annual drop since 2005
now today it fell to $11 18864 that's
the lowest since February the 27th 2006
and interestingly strategists we've
surveyed here at Bloomberg for forecast
the euro to slump to
$118 by the end of the year at the end
of last year 44 out of 59 analysts in a
Bloomberg survey said the Euro would
drop against the dollar the median
projection looking for a
2.5% decline through December the 31st
already in 2015 the Euro's Fallen by
1.2% versus the dollar now the most
bearish on the Euro are Barkley and City
Group they're forecasting a drop to
$17 Morgan Stanley forecasts
$112 as does saxo bank and RBS sock JN
BMP paraba forecasting
$15 on the bullish end of the spectrum
are Australia and New Zealand banking
group that's forecasting a rise to $129
Banos santand is penciling in 128 the
forecasts are all over the place but the
spotlight now very much on the ECB Mario
dragi of course the ECB president
starting the Year by telling the German
newspaper handles BL that the risk of
deflation in the Euro Zone can't be
excluded and that's bolstering
expectations the ECB will soon start
actions such as buying bonds which tend
to weaken a currency but the big date is
January the 22nd that's the next ECB
meeting ahead of that watch out for
Wednesday's your area inflation dat met
which may show consumer prices recorded
the first annual drop in more than 5
years in December because of the sliding
cost of the price of oil how low will
the Euro go in